So, when I need to get creative and
I'm feeling like I'm out of ideas,
a lot of times I'll look at other media,
like video games, or
movies, or television shows,
or just go for a walk.
Because a lot of times,
staring at Xcode,
and trying to get creative
is the exact wrong approach.
>> When I'm trying to get
creative in building an app,
I usually look to others
instead of myself.
So, I'll ask my twin brother or
my friends or family and just figure out
what problems they're going through and
figure out if there's a cool,
mobile way that we could solve them, and
then start building an app from there.
>> Having a problem to solve helps
me get in a creative mindset.
Because sort of defining
the problem gives me sort of
the space that I'm working within.
Chances are I know how that problem
has been solved previously and
I'm unhappy with those results.
So I have that, that gives me
the components that I'm working with,
the components that I want to change.